(dramatic music)
- Donald Trump gets a special prosecutor.
It's the biggest, most
beautiful specialist counsel
anyone has ever seen.
No one's ever seen a
prosecutor quite so special.
Grown men were weeping at
the sight of this counsel.
That joke never gets old.
In a Friday after the midterms news dump,
Attorney General Merrick Garland announced
that he has appointed a special counsel
to conduct two criminal investigations
related to Donald Trump.
This is extremely big news
that has so far kind of
flown under the radar,
but in all likelihood
this means big things.
In a super abundance of caution,
the attorney general has decided
that the Department of
Justice can't investigate
the former president
because he's running for president again
and it would look political.
- And isn't this sort
of like double jeopardy?
In the old days they used
to call it double jeopardy.
- Enter the special counsel.
No, not that guy.
- You're not that guy, pal.
Trust me, you're not that guy.
- This guy, Jack Smith.
Should Donald Trump celebrate?
Does this mean that there
will be a few more years
of Trump escaping justice,
or that prosecutions are
just around the horizon?
Well, by all counts,
Attorney General Merrick
Garland is an institutionalist.
Those that want to see a
former president put in jail
have criticized Garland for being too slow
and too methodical, or
just not doing anything.
And although some Republicans predicted
that Garland would use his office
to exact some kind of
revenge on Republicans,
the opposite has largely been true.
It appears that Garland decided
not to prosecute Matt
Gaetz or Rudy Giuliani.
And now Garland has issued an order
to appoint John L. Smith
to serve as special counsel
for the Department of Justice
to conduct two ongoing investigations
related to the former President Trump:
whether Trump unlawfully interfered
with the 2020 presidential election
and the certification of
the Electoral College vote
on January 6th,
and whether Trump broke any laws
when he removed classified documents
and other presidential records
from the White House to Mar-a-Lago.
Now, Congress has delegated
the authority of the attorney general
to appoint a special counsel.
28 U.S.C. 510 says, "The
attorney general may
"from time to time make such provisions
"as he considers appropriate
authorizing the performance
"by any other officer, employee, or agency
"of the Department of Justice
"of any function of the attorney general."
But the special counsel
does have real independence.
Under C.F.R. Section 600.7.,
"The special counsel shall not be subject
"to the day-to-day supervision
"of any official of the department.
"However, the attorney general may request
"that the special counsel
provide an explanation
"for any investigative
or prosecutorial step
"and may after review
conclude that the action
"was so inappropriate or unwarranted
"under established departmental practices
"that it should not be pursued.
"In concluding that review,
"the attorney general
will give great weight
"to the views of the special counsel.
"If the attorney general
concludes that a proposed action
"by a special counsel
should not be pursued,
"the attorney general
shall notify Congress."
And that section goes on to explain
that the special counsel can
only be removed for cause.
Now, Garland's order is broader
with respect to the first issue,
the certification over the
Electoral College vote.
Quote, "The special counsel is authorized
"to conduct the ongoing investigation
"into whether any person
or entity violated the law
"in connection with efforts to interfere
"with the lawful transfer of power
"following the 2020 presidential election
"or the certification of of
the Electoral College vote
"held on or about January 6, 2021,
"as well as any matters that arose
"or might arise directly
from this investigation
"or that are within the scope
of 28 C.F.R. Section 600.4a."
And continues, "This
authorization does not apply
"to prosecutions that
are currently pending
"in the District of Columbia,
"as well as future
investigations and prosecutions
"of individuals for
offenses they committed
"while physically present
on the Capitol grounds
"on January 6, 2021."
That means that people who
were on the Capitol grounds
will continue to be prosecuted by the DOJ
with the involvement
of the special counsel.
That means that the normies
who are not in Trump's inner circle
who were on the Capitol grounds
will continue to be prosecuted by the DOJ
without the involvement
of the special counsel.
The special counsel will
be looking at the role
that Trump and others who
were not at the Capitol,
but who were scheming for ways
for him to stay in office.
And as we've seen,
this is a fairly complicated investigation
that encompasses the plot
to use fake electors in multiple states.
It could also include
investigation of people
who planned the January 6 protests,
which could lead higher up the chain.
And the special counsel
order does not impact
ongoing state and local investigations,
such as the Fulton County's probe
into the fake elector plot.
There's currently a grand
jury considering evidence
in that case right now,
with possible defendants
including Donald Trump
and Senator Lindsey Graham.
And the special counsel
will also take over
the investigation into
the Mar-a-Lago documents.
Quote, "The special counsel
is further authorized
"to conduct the ongoing
investigation referenced
"and described in the
United States' Response
"to Motion for Judicial
Oversight and Additional Relief,
"Donald J. Trump v. United States,
"as well as any matters that arose
"or may arise directly
from this investigation
"or that are within the
scope of 28 C.F.R. 600.4a."
So the question is, why a special counsel?
The special or independent
counsel at the federal level
has been around in one form or
another for almost 150 years.
The first independent
counsel was appointed
by President Ulysses S. Grant
to investigate corruption
at the high level of
federal government officials
in his administration.
And just how independent
these special prosecutors were
depended on the laws
governing their appointment.
After the fallout from Watergate,
Congress passed the Ethics
in Government Act of 1978
which authorized the appointment
of independent counsels.
Under the act, the attorney
general would conduct
an initial investigation to determine
whether an independent
investigation was warranted.
If it was, then a three-judge
panel of federal judges
would appoint an independent counsel.
That act was used to investigate
Bill Clinton initially
for his Whitewater real estate deals,
which eventually turned
into an investigation
over his affair with Monica Lewinsky
and obstruction of justice.
In 1999, the statute expired
and Congress did not reauthorize it
in part because the
Democrats probably believed
that the independent counsel
was a little too independent.
But obviously there was still a need
for an independent investigative process,
so in 1999, the DOJ
promulgated regulations
to establish procedures
for the appointment of special counsels
pursuant to the attorney general's
general administrative hiring authority.
Special counsels serve a similar role
as independent counsels, but
they have less independence.
The attorney general
generally has the authority
to appoint, supervise, and remove them.
That said, we have an example
where that kind of independence
was directly challenged.
Richard Nixon's attorney
general, Elliot Richardson,
hired Archibald Cox as
a special prosecutor
relating to the Watergate affair.
The AG had sole authority to fire Cox
and only for extraordinary improprieties,
but Nixon eventually
tired of the investigation
and ordered Richardson to fire Cox.
Richardson famously refused
and immediately resigned.
Nixon then ordered Deputy Attorney General
William Ruckelshaus to fire Cox.
Ruckelshaus refused and also resigned.
Nixon finally ordered
Solicitor General Robert Bork,
the number three at the DOJ,
to fire Cox, and Bork complied.
The special prosecutor was out of a job.
So while the modern
special counsel regulations
contemplate independence,
it's hard to refuse
the head of the executive branch.
The special counsel is funded
by the Independent Counsel Appropriation,
a permanent indefinite
appropriation established
in the Justice Department's
1988 Appropriations Act,
and that means that the money comes
from a permanent Treasury
Department account
and isn't subject to the
annual appropriations process.
And the attorney general controls
the special counsel budget,
so Congress can't defund
Jack Smith in this case.
The special counsel
reports directly to the AG,
and if he determines that, say,
Donald Trump should be charged,
the special counsel has to
notify Attorney General Garland.
The regulation says, quote,
"The special counsel shall
notify the attorney general
"of events in the course
of his or her investigation
"in conformity with the
departmental guidelines
"with respect to urgent reports."
Congress also has the right to know
what the special counsel is doing.
The regulation says, quote,
"The attorney general will notify
"the chairman ranking minority member
"of the judiciary committees
of each House of Congress,
"with an explanation for each action,
"one, upon appointing a special counsel,
"two, upon removing any special counsel,
"and three, upon conclusion
"of the special counsel's investigation,
"including to the extent
consistent with applicable law
"a description and explanation
of instances, if any,
"in which the attorney general concluded
"that a proposed action
by a special counsel
"was so inappropriate or unwarranted
"under established departmental practices
"that it should not be pursued."
So, Congress will be notified
about the outcome of the
Trump-related investigations.
But another question, why
a special counsel now?
Although some have questioned
whether Garland made the right decision,
the regulations seem to
contemplate a situation like this.
It states that the attorney
general will appoint
a special counsel to conduct
certain investigations
or prosecutions, and those
regulations are set forth
in 28 C.F.R. 600.1, which
establishes a three-part analysis
for determining whether to
appoint a special counsel.
First, the attorney general
must determine that, quote,
"A criminal investigation of a person
"or matter is warranted.
"Then the attorney general must determine
"whether the investigation
or prosecution of the person
"or matter by the U.S. Attorney's Office
"or a Justice Department
litigating division
"would present either
a conflict of interest
"for the department or an
extraordinary circumstance.
"Third, the attorney general must consider
"whether it would be
in the public interest
"to appoint an outside special counsel
"to assume responsibility in the matter."
So while Garland's order doesn't specify
on what grounds he appointed Smith,
in his speech announcing the
appointment he said, quote-
- Based on recent developments,
including the former
president's announcement
that he is a candidate for
president in the next election,
and the sitting president's
stated intention
to be a candidate as well,
I have concluded that it
is in the public interest
to appoint a special counsel.
- And in the next breath, he points out
that Donald Trump had
announced his candidacy
to become president again,
and President Biden had indicated
that he would run for reelection.
So those might indicate either
an extraordinary circumstance
or a conflict of interest
between the sitting president
and potential future president.
Though on the other
hand, there's an argument
that there's no actual
conflict of interest
that would preclude the DOJ
from handling investigations normally,
just like they did before
President Trump announced
he was running for president.
He is, after all, just a
U.S. citizen at this point.
Garland has been overseeing
the investigation
into the events of
January 6 for two years,
and any perceived conflict
might have already existed
during that time,
and yet there was no special
counsel at that point.
Though certainly appointing
Smith as special counsel
has not eliminated political criticism.
Senator Ted Cruz said that
the timing of the appointment
was proof that the investigation
was politically motivated.
Cruz said, quote, "Three
days ago, Trump announced
"and now there is a special counsel.
"This is Trump derangement syndrome,
"but this time with a gun and a badge."
Meanwhile, the House Judiciary Committee
attacked Smith's impartiality.
Quote, "Jack Smith and his
buddies have been politicizing
"Washington for ages,
"and he's who AG Garland picked
to be the special counsel
"to, quote, 'investigate' President Trump?
"Come on."
And on the other end of the spectrum,
people who believe that
Trump committed crimes
and got away with them have scoffed
at the appointment of a special counsel.
They contend that this
investigation will end
the way that the Mueller investigation did
with a report rather than a prosecution,
though this doesn't seem
to be totally accurate.
First of all, the Mueller
investigation did lead
to 34 people and three
companies to be indicted.
And, of course, President Trump
was not one of those people,
but there are reasons for that.
You can certainly disagree with them,
but there were reasons.
The attorney general has sole authority
to determine the scope of the
special counsel's inquiry,
and then President
Trump's attorneys general
wanted to limit the
special counsel's work.
And under the mandate
and Mueller's interpretation
of that mandate,
Mueller was not allowed
to accuse President Trump
of a crime.
Now, Mueller was also constrained
by the Office of Legal Counsel memo
that says a sitting
president cannot be indicted
while he's in office.
That memo's conclusion is controversial
and the Supreme Court
has never ruled on that,
however, the Justice Department employees
do follow the OLC memo.
So the Mueller report
outlined over 10 instances
of obstruction of justice
that implicated Trump,
however, even if Mueller had
the authority to charge Trump,
he believed that he was
bound by the OLC guidance
on indicting sitting presidents.
The Smith appointment as special counsel
is markedly different
because Garland gave him a
broad mandate to investigate
and prosecute Trump if
the evidence is there.
The posture of the case
is also very different.
There were multiple grand
juries weighing evidence
that Trump interfered
with the certification
of the 2020 election and
that he broke the law
by taking documents to Mar-a-Lago.
In addition, there's no
memorandum or court case anywhere
that suggests it's illegal
to prosecute an ex-president.
And Smith will have to
follow the DOJ's guidance
on when it is appropriate to
recommend criminal charges.
Section 9-27.220 of the DOJ's
manual outlines the grounds
for commencing or declining prosecution.
It states, quote, "The
attorney for the government
"should commence or
recommend federal prosecution
"if he/she believes that
the person's conduct
"constitutes a federal offense
"and that the admissible evidence
"will probably be sufficient
"to obtain and sustain a conviction
"unless, one, the prosecution would serve
"no substantial federal interest;
"two, the person is subject
to effective prosecution
"in another jurisdiction;
"or three, there exists an adequate
"non-criminal alternative to prosecution."
So now you might be
wondering who is Jack Smith,
the new special counsel?
Well, he is a 50-year-old
graduate of Harvard Law School
who started his career as a prosecutor
in the Manhattan District
Attorney's Office.
Smith then moved to the U.S.
Attorney's Office in Brooklyn
where he worked on
public corruption cases.
Smith then spent two years
as the investigation coordinator
in the office of the prosecutor
at the International
Criminal Court in the Hague.
Smith supervised high
profile investigations,
so people wanted for
war crimes and genocide.
From 2010 to 2015, Smith was chief
of the DOJ's Public Integrity Section
which investigates public
corruption allegations.
And while in that role,
Smith investigated high
profile politicians
on both sides of the aisle,
which really seemed to piss
off just about everyone.
The Public Integrity
Section was under fire
for a case against former
senator Ted Stevens
which collapsed.
During Smith's first
few months on the job,
he closed investigations
into several Republican
members of Congress.
During his years as chief,
the Public Integrity Section garnered
a successful conviction
against former Republican
governor Bob McDonnell,
which was later unanimously
overturned by the Supreme Court.
And then the Obama administration
chose not to continue
prosecution after that reversal.
Smith also pursued a case
against Democratic vice
presidential candidate
and former senator John Edwards,
which resulted in a hung
jury and a mistrial.
Smith also helped lead the investigation
into Democrat Bob Menendez,
though he left the department
a few months before the indictment,
though Menendez was later acquitted.
His team won a conviction against
Representative Rick Renzi,
a Republican from Arizona
who was sentenced to
three years in prison,
though Trump pardoned Renzi
right before he left office
in early 2021.
For his own part,
Smith said that the pace
of the Trump investigations
would not slow down under his watch.
He said, quote, "I intend to conduct
"the assigned investigations,
"and any prosecutions
that may result from them,
"independently and in the best traditions
"of the Department of Justice."
Mr. Smith said that in
a statement he vowed
that the investigations would
move forward expeditiously,
quote, "To whatever outcome
the facts and law dictate."
Though the "New York Times"
reports that Smith, quote,
"Will remain in the
Netherlands for some time,
"according to the Justice Department,
"in order to recover from
a recent bicycle accident."
Though the 11th Circuit
held oral arguments
in the Mar-a-Lago case on the
Tuesday before Thanksgiving,
and although Smith remains overseas,
the DOJ filed notice
that he was on the case.
Quote, "Special Counsel Smith
has reviewed the filings
"in this litigation and
approves all of the arguments
"that have been presented in the briefs
"and will be discussed at the
oral argument in this case.
"Special Counsel Smith's
name will be affixed
"to future pleadings filed in all matters
"falling within his appointment."
So while the appointment of
Jack Smith as special counsel
gives a little bit for everyone to hate,
net-net it's probably not good news
for former President Trump.
Certainly it probably means
delays in the short term,
but Jack Smith has an
advantage over Robert Mueller
who had to hire
investigators and prosecutors
and start from scratch.
Smith gets to hit the ground running.
He'll supervise DOJ prosecutors
who are already on the case,
and the DOJ has issued subpoenas,
served a search warrant on Mar-a-Lago,
and are in court battling Trump
over the appointment
of the special master.
And the special counsel
has hit the ground running.
Smith now oversees the
ongoing investigation
into Trump's efforts to
overturn the 2020 election,
and Smith's office just issued subpoenas
to elections officials in
Allegheny County, Pennsylvania,
Dane County, Wisconsin,
Wayne County, Michigan,
and Maricopa County, Arizona.
The subpoenas seek
documents and communications
they had with 19 people,
including Trump and some of
his most well-known associates
like looney lawyer Lin Wood,
Sidney the Kraken Powell,
Rudy Giuliani, Cleta
Mitchell, and Bernie Kerik.
Realistically, the appointment of Smith
probably does nothing to mollify
the political critics of it
who will say that this is
a political prosecution,
but still, appointing a special counsel
is probably still better than main justice
under the aegis of AG Garland
doing the prosecution.
And while trying to figure out
what's going to happen next
is reading tea leaves,
it probably doesn't mean that
nothing is going to happen.
In other words, Garland probably would not
have appointed a special counsel
if he had determined that no
prosecution was warranted.
And I think that Smith's experience shows
that he prosecutes hard cases.
Often the DOJ will only take a case
if they think that they are sure to win,
but it looks like Smith's record
doesn't follow that adage.
Public integrity cases
are notoriously difficult,
and the reason that the
Supreme Court has overturned
some of these convictions
is that drawing the line
between political action and
bribery is very tough to do,
let alone to get convictions
in these politically sensitive cases.
Though here, at least
with respect to documents,
that is a much, much simpler
case than political bribery.
But while Special Counsel Smith is resting
his bicycle injury and
getting up to speed,
he'll want some legal
audiobooks to listen to.
He might enjoy John
Grisham's new legal thriller
"The Judge's List" on
today's sponsor, Audible.
It's all about a judge who
is also a serial killer
and uses the law against
his investigators,
because a killer who
knows how to manipulate
the legal system is the
scariest killer of all.
Ooh!
Now, I use Audible almost every day,
and it's by far the best
source of audio entertainment.
I listen to audiobooks when
I'm running, cleaning up,
or when I'm supposed to
be listening to friends
and loved ones.
Audible is the leading provider
of spoken word entertainment
all in one place.
If you tried to listen to everything,
it would take you three centuries.
And as an Audible member, you'll
get one credit every month
that you can use on any title
in their entire premium catalog.
That includes basically every bestseller,
new release, or memoir.
Those titles are yours to keep forever
in your Audible library.
And you'll also get full access
to their popular Plus Catalogue
which is filled with thousands
and thousands of audiobooks,
original entertainment,
guided fitness and meditation,
sleep tracks, and shows.
All are included with your
membership, no credits needed.
And right now Audible is
running a special promo.
New Audible members get
a free one-month trial.
You can try it out and see
why everyone loves Audible.
All you have to do is go
to audible.com/LegalEagle
or click on the link
that's on screen right now
or in the description.
So right now, for a limited
time, get a free one-month trial
of Audible by clicking on the link below.
And after that, click
on this box over here
for more LegalEagle, or
I'll see you in court.